I've always had a strange notion that
anybody who's severely depressed should
actually make a documentary about
themselves in their life as if it was
from a third person and is if they had
passed to see all the gifts that they
have in their life and their traits and
you definitely see that when you watch
the film and it is beautiful and at the
same time sad and that you also look at
your own life and say wow I've taken so
much for granted what would you
recommend to another family another
person who whatever the subject is
having someone come into their life and
and filming intimate moments and things
that are quite devastating to most
people what would you tell them how
would they prepare themselves and how
did you approach it I think that I think
when people watch the film for the first
time they don't realize or what you
don't see is that Neil and I lost our
privacy a long time before the camera
actually arrived in the house and you
know it was very hard for us to stay as
our little Ian of 3am and we'd only just
become that billion of three so we tried
very hard and to try and cope on her own
as long as possible but I think that
perhaps we could have asked for he'll
probably bit earlier and but once that
help did start flowing and started
coming through the door at that point I
think that's when you feel that you're
losing your privacy and in a way having
the camera there for Neil clawed back a
little bit of that privacy for him he
was so physically dependent on everybody
around him that um you know I was never
very far from hovering at the door in
case he was choking or all right you
know he needed any physical help in some
way or anything happened with his
ventilator the only I knew how to solve
for him so it was very good he rarely
experienced a closed door
but when Emma came down with a camera
and just let him speak I mean you were
in the room with him and you're asking
questions and I wasn't far from hovering
from the door but I think because it was
am asking the questions and more
regolith of it as well I think she was
but I think when it was just you and
Neil I think because you you didn't know
each other as well as Morrigan Neil then
that's when he began to really feel a
bit of a release actually he knew that
he was seeing things that would be
recorded and that he could you know pass
on to Oscar and I think he really really
benefited from it he really benefited
from that emotional release I am I
certainly you know there was certainly I
kind of calm in the house when you left
I think yeah I remember one time
arriving and and you synced Morrigan
myself thank goodness you've come he's
got so much to say and you were like
just go and he was really waiting to
speak and you felt that and this had
been building up like a damn and it
needed expression and in a way I mean it
is incredible that a man who couldn't
move from the neck down is still
communicating with people all over the
world through this film and through his
determination to reach out and i think
it was in those moments that that
incredible urge would express itself but
maybe it's also a wee bit he knew as he
said in the film that he only had this
one freedom which was the freedom to
communicate and that was a devastating
discussion that we had when Morrigan I
in advance had decided that we had to
ask this really difficult question of
what do you miss most and it did feel
very you know a very hard thing to to
ask him and he went through every part
of his body saying what he missed he
talked about you know what he missed him
with his feet what he missed doing with
his leg
how he missed hugging his friends cuz he
was a hugger hmm he really was and then
he talked about and this really i think
you know certainly affected us a loss at
the time when he said the thing that he
really messed was just pushing his child
nuh pushed here and that felt like how
simple could you get just missing
pushing your child in a push to you and
i think being able to be as specific as
that with each thing allows us as an
audience to enter that experience of
loss of loss of the movement of loss of
who he was so then the question comes
well who are we as human beings and
weird as our humanness when does our
humanity goal and i think these were the
questions that new was asking of his
life is how long could he keep hold of
his humanity and i think actually
towards the end a much bigger humanity
came out and certainly for me and more
like looking at him anyway it felt like
something quite immense and incredible
came from from his suffering and from
his his desire not to just treat it as
suffering as an end in itself but to
think what he could learn to share with
other people and that's when it wasn't
just about ALS or MND but about as you
said about time and about realizing that
he had something to say about an
awareness of life
you